Bonsoir, moi c'est JH
je sais pas si vous savez mais
tous les canapés avec une pastille rouge sont à moins vingt pourcents en ce moment.
Donc profitez-en.
Avant que je les achète tous.
Je sais que c'est un gros investissement
je vous laisse le temps de réfléchir, vous inquiétez pas, prenez votre temps.
- Merci beaucoup.
- Je sais pas ce que t'en penses
C'est bon ?
Ne vous inquiétez pas, on va trouver une option de financement
on va aller dans mon bureau, on va regarder ça
on va trouver quelque chose.
Sylvie, ta caisse elle a quel âge, elle a 2000 ans ?
Faut la changer un jour, tu sais, elle marche au charbon
elle fait des trous d'un couche d'ozone quand elle roule
elle regarde, elle fait "désolé c'est pas moi".
elle fume pas, elle tousse "D'où ça vient ? Je sais pas"
Faut faire quelque chose.
JH, t'as jamais pensé à faire du stand up ?
Non.
Franchement tu devrais.
Juste pour vous dire qu'on a fait un super chiffre cette semaine
et encore bravo à Karim et a Jean-Hugues.
JH.
C'est la même chose.
Non, c'est pas pareil. JH.
OK, comme tu veux JH. Bon appétit.
Merci.
Prends une trottinette.
- Ça va mon coeur ?
- Ouais.
T'as passé une bonne journée ?
Très bien oui.
Je me suis battu avec mon patron
je suis parti à contre-sens sur le périph
j'ai écrasé quelqu'un, les flics m'ont arrêté, ils m'ont dit
Vous pouvez y aller, ça arrive.
- Et toi ?
- Moi le téléphone a pas arrêté de sonner
j'ai eu un coup de fil de Mark Zuckerberg, il m'a commandé une toile
un nu de lui pour 10 millions de dollars.
- Oui il fait souvent ça.
- Ouais.
C'est son style.
- Donc ça c'est Mark Zuckerberg alors ?
- Oui c'est lui.
Tu vois pas ?
Il manque un petit détail quand même.
- Qu'est-ce qu'il manque ?
- Une bite.
- S'il-te-plaît Leïla, laisse-moi faire une bite.
- Non, je crois pas.
Tu loupes quelque chose.
- Mais t'aimes bien ?
- Mais oui, c'est super.
Bravo ! À ta santé, Thib !
Thib qui a la même gueule depuis qu'il a 7 ans.
Il a juste grandi, c'est tout.
Vous avez vu ? Il y a Jamel.
C'est marrant de le voir là.
Je crois qu'il a sa salle à côté, c'est pour ça.
Tu veux pas aller lui parler ?
Tu m'en parles souvent d'essayer le stand-up.
Là c'est l'occasion.
- Je sais pas.
- Et tu peux lui demander des conseils.
Ça va le déranger.
Mais non, il faut essayer.
- Tu crois ?
- Mais oui.
Vas-y.
Picon bière.
- Qui a pris une boisson de personnes âgées ici ?
- Moi.
Oui, forcément, je savais qui c'était.
Parle-nous un peu de ton voyage.
J'ai une trop bonne nouvelle aujourd'hui.
Tu te souviens du resto La Penderie, là où je travaillais ?
J'ai gardé contact avec la patronne
et elle a accepté de m'exposer pendant quelques semaines.
Tes toiles ?
Oui mes toiles, pourquoi ?
Non comme ça.
Elles méritent pas d'être exposées, mes toiles ?
Si, bien sûr, je suis surpris c'est tout.
Je sais pas, tu pourrais être content pour moi.
Je suis content pour toi. C'est très bien.
C'est juste que je rentre, j'ai la tête comme ça et tu m'enchaînes.
En ce moment pour l'achat d'un canapé
trois places ou plus
recevez un fauteuil kiwi gratuitement.
Profitez-en
Joyeux anniversaire mon cœur !
- C'est ça ta surprise ?
- Ouais.
- C'est cool, non ?
On va voir un plateau de stand-up.
Tu connais ? Il y a plein d'humoristes qui s'enchaînent.
Ah. Jamais entendu parler non.
Du stand-up, comme par hasard.
Non pas du tout, c'est pas pour te mettre la pression
c'est juste que ça te ferait pas de mal de rire un petit peu.
Oui tu as raison.
C'est une super surprise, merci.
Je le savais.
Bonsoir le Comedy Showcase, ça va ?
Super, vous allez passer un excellent moment
on a sélectionné des artistes formidables
on va commencer par la première, vous êtes prêts ?
Faites du bruit pour Doully.
Du bruit pour Djimo s'il-vous-plaît.
Je suis désolée, il faut vraiment que je décroche.
Je reviens.
Est-ce que vous êtes prêts à accueillir le prochain ?
C'est la première fois qu'il vient ici donc je compte sur vous pour l'accueillir chaleureusement.
Faites du bruit pour Dji, mesdames et messieurs.
Bonsoir.
Merci Yacine, même si je suis déjà venu dix fois à peu près.
C'est pas grave, de toute façon j'aime pas ce mec.
je me présente je m'appelle Dji
et avant d'être humoriste j'avais un autre métier
je sauvais des gens.
J'étais vendeur de canapé.
J'ai arrêté ce métier le jour je me suis dit, tu sais
ce qui est bien en étant vendeur de canapé c'est que
j'ai pas réussi à terminer cette phrase.
dans mon ancien métier il y avait quand même un petit avantage
C'est une blague ou...
On se voit dans les coulisses ?
Voilà, c'est tout pour moi.
Faites du bruit pour le prochain.
Pardon.
Je suis désolée, c'était un coup de fil hyper urgent.
Tu vas où ?
C'est hyper compliqué à expliquer.
Tu vas aux toilettes ?
Ouais voilà ouais.
Et c'est compliqué a expliquer ?
Écoute, je reviens, OK ?
Putain mec, on se ressemble comme deux
gouttes d'eau, c'est ouf.
Je comprends pas.
- Merde.
- Quoi ?
On a la même voix en plus.
Vas-y, dis quelque chose pour voir ?
- Toilettes japonaises ?
- C'est fou...
Comment tu t'appelles ?
Moi c'est Dji, et toi ?
Moi tout le monde m'appelle JH.
Tu t'appelles Jean-Hughes.
Comment tu sais ?
Non c'est moi Jean-Hugues.
Dji c'est un nom de scène parce que je peux pas saquer mon prénom.
- OK, aujourd'hui c'est ton anniversaire ?
- Ouais.
T'es né à Angoulême, parents divorcés, mère au foyer
père expert-comptable, Jean-Phi le grand frère
qui t'a mis la misère quand t'étais jeune et qui a repris l'activité du daron, c'est ça ?
T'avais un poster de Jessica Alba au dessus de ton lit quand était ado
tu t'es beaucoup branlé en la regardant ?
Non, ça non, ça me dit rien.
Putain mec, on est exactement la même personne.
sauf que moi je me suis branlé de ouf en regardant Jessica Alba.
En fait si.
La branlette, Jessica Alba, si ça me revient.
Dji, on fait les saluts sur scène.
Il faut que tout le monde soit là.
J'arrive ouais.
- Attends-moi à la sortie.
- D'accord
JH, t'es là.
Je suis désolée, j'ai ma pote Estelle qui est vraiment trop dans le mal
elle s'est faite larguer par son mec, je peux pas la laisser toute seule.
Donc je vais y aller.
- OK.
- OK ?
- Tu m'en veux pas ?
- Non non.
- Je suis désolée.
- Je rentre après le spectacle.
OK, je te dis quand je rentre.
Putain c'est fou.
Je pensais que je venais de rêver, mais non.
T'existes vraiment.
T'es bien réel.
Pas contre faut vraiment qu'on trouve une explication.
On peut aller se poser chez moi si tu veux.
Enfin, chez nous.
T'habites toujours à Clichy ?
Bah oui, pas toi ?
Non, j'ai déménagé.
Ok, on est des jumeaux séparés à la naissance.
Non c'est pas possible, on a la même vie.
Ouais. Ou alors
t'es mon "moi du passé" et moi je viens pour te prévenir
que dans le futur
y'a rien de spécial.
Non, j'y ai pensé, c'est pas possible.
- T'as bien trente ans aujourd'hui ?
- Ouais.
Voilà ,on a le même âge, tu peux pas venir du futur.
C'est vrai.
Et t'es plus vendeur alors ?
Non, je me suis lancé à fond dans le-stand up.
C'est Jamel qui m'a conseillé de trouver du temps
pour me lancer, pour écrire mon spectacle.
Attends, tu connais Jamel ?
Ouais. Je l'ai rencontré par hasard à l'anniversaire de Thib.
C'est pas Jamel ?
et du coup, je suis allé le voir.
Jamel, excuse-moi de te déranger
est-ce que tu aurais des conseils pour quelqu'un qui veut se lancer dans le stand-up ?
Je lui ai demandé des conseils, il m'a donné surtout beaucoup de contacts
pour m'entraîner, pour faire mes scènes partout.
Passe mardi, peut-être que j'y serai, on sait jamais.
- Grave ! Merci !
- Salut.
Picon bière.
En fait c'est là ou nos vies sont différentes.
T'es pas mon mois du futur ou je sais pas quoi.
J'y étais à l'anniversaire de Thib
j'ai croisé Jamel, sauf que
on n'a pas discuté.
Pourquoi ?
Il est passé vite
j'ai pas eu le temps, il était occupé
T'as pas osé quoi.
Non, c'est juste que j'allais pas le déranger et puis
j'avais peur, enfin peut-être qu'il allait pas me trouver drôle
- Je sais pas.
- Tu te prends trop la tête.
Franchement moi j'y suis allé et
Bon c'est vrai que j'étais hyper stressée en fait
Et le stand-up, ça marche pour nous ?
Pour moi ?
Ouais carrément.
Écoute je fais pas mal de premières parties.
J'ai un petit spectacle qui se construit comme ça
et surtout j'ai eu un passage à la télévision
il y a eu des extraits sur youtube, ça cartonne bien
Mec, je trouve plus mes sketches sur YouTube
J'existe plus sur internet.
Dji, les mariages, 2 millions de vues sur YouTube, c'est où ça ?
Si t'es venu dans ma dimension
faut qu'on trouve un moyen pour que tu rentres chez toi.
C'est cool de revenir ici.
Attends, je vais ouvrir.
C'était pas fermé.
T'enlèves tes chaussures.
Surprise !
Joyeux anniversaire !
Attends, attends.
T'as rien à faire ici. On se voit plus tard.
Il va revenir ?
Vous êtes des petits cachotiers vous.
Merci pour la surprise, franchement c'est fou.
Tu viens de te changer ?
Ouais pour faire plus propre quoi.
Tu t'en doutais pas !
Non j'ai rien vu venir.
Je pense qu'il ya des retardataires.
Bougez pas, je reviens OK ?
Quoi ?
On est encore avec Leila ?
Oui, mais c'est pas le moment là.
Il faudrait que j'aille lui parler.
Mais tu peux pas parce que t'existes pas ici.
Tu comprends ça ? On se voit demain, d'accord ?
Mais j'ai nul part où aller, j'ai pas d'appart ici.
Tu vas chez maman, OK ?
Il y a encore ma chambre là-bas. Notre chambre.
À demain.
C'était une erreur.
On va mettre un peu de musique ?
Merci d'être là en tout cas, ça me fait super plaisir, vraiment.
C'est normal JH.
JH.
Je suis désolée, j'ai eu des problèmes de transport.
- Pas de soucis.
- Bon anniversaire.
- Merci.
- Tu vas où ?
T'inquiètes, tout le monde est là, je reviens dans 2 minutes.
Les gens ! JH va nous faire un discours !
Un discours ! Un discours !
Merci d'être là. Tous.
Ok. C'était un beau discours de merde.
Allez à ta santé JH.
C'est marrant, cette chambre a pas bougé en dix ans.
- Tiens.
- Merci.
Un dégât des eaux le jour de son anniversaire.
C'est juste de l'eau qui coule dans la chambre, t'inquiètes pas
ça va être vite réglé.
Et Leïla ?
Leïla, elle est chez ses parents.
D'accord.
Désolé de t'avoir dérangé dans la nuit comme ça.
Mais c'est rien mon grand
je suis contente de t'avoir à la maison tu sais.
C'est bizarre, t'es pas comme d'habitude. T'es différent.
Allez, tu vas te coucher parce que demain
au magasin tu vas être fatigué sinon.
Maman.
Est ce que tu crois aux mondes parallèles ?
Comme dans les films de science fiction ?
Non, laisse tomber, oublie.
Ça me rappelle le jour de mes trente ans.
C'était une journée bien particulière.
Oublie, de toute façon tu me croirais pas.
Allez, bonne nuit.
Karim, ça fait longtemps.
Depuis hier, ouais.
T'es toujours là.
Il faut qu'on se parle.
Et moi il faut que je travaille, tu veux pas qu'on soit à l'heure plutôt ?
Écoute je crois c'est déjà arrivé à maman
et je pense que je suis dans ton monde que pour 24 heures.
et ce soir je serai plus là.
C'est vrai ?
Tu dois être soulagé alors.
Mais non, mais du coup tu dois te lancer ce soir.
Non attends je suis pas prêt moi
je peux pas me lancer ce soir, c'est pas possible, j'ai pas de texte, j'ai rien.
Je vais te coacher et ce soir tu montes sur scène
Après je serai plus là.
Tu me fais confiance ?
Ouais.
Allo Slim, c'est Dji, ça va ?
C'est JH pardon, on se connaît pas
dis-moi, j'ai eu ton contact par Yacine
et est-ce que tu as une place de libre sur le plateau de ce soir, à tout hasard ?
Ouais ce serait cool.
Ouais j'ai de l'expérience.
Non, j'ai pas d'expérience, c'est la première fois que je fais ça.
Par contre je suis un mec hyper drôle
le mec le plus drôle de la région parisienne.
Super. OK, à ce soir alors. Merci.
La bise à Sarah.
Je m'y ferai jamais.
C'est bon pour ce soir.
Par contre j'ai rien préparé, t'es au courant de ça ?
Donc faut que tu me files des vannes.
Non ça c'est du plagiat.
Non, tes vannes c'est mes vannes, tu vas pas faire ton CopyComic.
Non, ça c'est du plagiat entre dimension, ça reste du plagiat.
Je vais me prendre un bide c'est sûr, aide-moi s'il-te-plaît.
T'inquiètes, t'as noté plein de vannes dans ton téléphone.
Non.
Si.
Non, ça me dit rien.
Mec, toi c'est moi, tu peux pas me douiller.
Qu'est-ce que je peux être con parfois.
Allez, on y va.
- Je fais quoi ?
- Tu racontes tes vannes
et moi je te coache, je te dis comment faire, OK ?
Sauf la vanne sur la fête foraine
ça bide à chaque fois
je l'ai faites trois fois sur scène, ça marche pas, je sais pas pourquoi.
Allez, tiens.
L'esclavage a été aboli en France, pourtant je me souviens avoir été stagiaire.
Ok, ça c'est de la merde.
Le thème des stagiaires c'est super mais tu vas trop vite.
Prends ton temps, tu es stressé,
tu déballes tout comme ça
t'inquiètes on a le temps.
J'ai compris ça va.
Vas-y.
L'esclavage a été aboli en France, pourtant je me souviens avoir été stagiaire.
Ok, c'est mieux
mais la posture déjà, ça va pas du tout.
Je sais pas, tiens bien ton micro déjà
et puis, ai l'air relax.
Non c'est de la merde, vas-y je te montre.
- Jean-Hugues ?
- JH.
Dis-moi, à qui tu parles depuis ce matin ?
Un client.
Un gros client.
Je suis en train de lui faire acheter tout magasin là.
Un chiffre d'affaire de ouf.
- Ça te plaît ça ?
- C'est super.
Franchement merci, c'est sympa de ma part.
Sympa de ma part, c'est pas mal ça.
On pose ça là.
Poulet-cacahuètes, c'est bon ça, bonne idée.
Ouais, on a les mêmes goûts.
Ça va avec Leïla ?
Je sais pas.
Je me demande si on n'a peut-être pas besoin de nouveau en fait.
Tu sais quand j'ai commencé le stand-up, moi aussi j'avais besoin de nouveau.
Alors j'ai tout quitté, je suis reparti à zéro.
Et je sais pas si c'est le poids de mon ancienne vie qui s'est volatilisé trop d'un coup mais
j'ai été très arogant.
Je pense qu'il y a un truc qui va pas.
Il fallait te donner un coup de boost et toi tu peux me jarter de ta vie ?
Elle m'en a voulu.
Et c'est normal, j'étais un gros con.
Moi je suis restée exactement comme je suis.
Maintenant tu me laisses.
Moi j'ai pas choisi ça.
Alors elle a pris ses affaires
elle est partie à l'étranger
et là actuellement, je pense qu'elle est dans un petit deux pièces
sur la face cachée de la lune, bien loin de moi.
Les semaines passent et tout se passe bien
sauf qu'au bout d'un moment, à chaque fois que je monte sur scène, je pense à elle
Et penser à son ex quand tu fais des blagues
c'est pas une bonne idée.
Mais c'est cool je me fais des thunes
je rencontre du monde, je fais rire des gens.
Mais je fais pas rire la bonne personne.
Tu sais c'est dur
quand tu descends de scène et tu attends qu'une chose c'est la croiser
mais non la dernière image que t'as de Leïla c'est elle
en pleurs, en train de t'insulter.
Après peut-être qu'on n'est pas exactement pareil ?
Le sandwich poulet-cacahuètes
C'est vrai.
On est les seuls à acheter ça à la boulangerie.
Je sais exactement où tu en es.
T'es perdu parce que t'as pas trouvé ta place.
Et moi je te le dis, notre place c'est avec Leïla.
Donne tout ce que tu as ce soir.
Attends mais tu vas où ?
Je suis pas prêt pour ce soir moi.
T'inquiètes, t'as toujours été prêt.
Et je bouge ça comment, moi ?
Alors ?
Tu lui as vendu quoi ?
Le gros client ?
Ah, rien.
Il voulait acheter une voiture.
Une voiture ?
Putain il utilise mon numéro.
Patron, je vais partir plus tôt aujourd'hui.
Je vais partir maintenant même.
Ça va ?
Je suis tellement content de te voir.
T'es bizarre là.
Ce que je vais te dire est très important pour moi, d'accord ?
OK.
Je suis désolé.
Je suis désolé et j'ai complètement merdé
et je comprends que tu sois partie loin et que tu veuilles plus voir ma gueule.
Je comprends.
De quoi tu parles ?
Il faut que tu saches que tu es la personne la plus incroyable que je connaisse.
J'aime ta manière de vivre, de voir le monde
j'aime quand tu acceptes les différences
j'aime tes peintures
j'aime ton sourire.
Je sais que tu comprends pas ce que je te dis là
J'ai du mal à me rendre compte de la chance que j'ai de t'avoir à mes côtés
Ce soir je vais faire deux trucs un petit peu fou.
D'abord je vais monter sur scène pour la première fois de ma vie.
J'aimerais que tu sois là.
C'est vrai ?
C'est génial, bien sûr que je serai là.
Et c'est quoi l'autre truc ?
Je reviens.
Qu'est-ce que tu fous ?
Tu dois pas être avec Leïla.
Il fallait vraiment que je la vois une dernière fois.
Attends, tu fais quoi là ?
Maintenant c'est à ton tour.
Mon tour de quoi ?
Est-ce que tu veux m'épouser ?
Un maximum de bruit pour le prochain
C'est sa première fois sur scène, il s'appelle JH.
Bonsoir.
Je m'appelle Jean-Hugues.
J'ai pas choisi ce prénom.
Je trouve que Jean-Hugues c'est pas un prénom que tu donnes à un bébé.
Je pense que ma mère elle voulait directement accoucher
d'un expert comptable de 60 ans.
C'est pas un prénom que je vis très bien.
Quand j'étais au collège par exemple on était que deux à s'appeler comme ça.
C'était moi et le proviseur.
Le proviseur je le croisais dans les couloirs,
il me faisait des
et moi je faisais des
J'ai quand même demandé à ma mère pourquoi elle a voulu
gâcher ma vie
Mais t'as vu l'heure toi ?
Mais au moins préviens-moi quand t'es en retard.
Patron je voulais vous prévenir d'autre chose.
Je démissionne.
Quoi ?
Mais tu vas où là ?
J'ai un spectacle à écrire.
Mais c'est une blague ou quoi ?
Mais JH !
Jean-Hugues.
Oh merde.
Tu t'es lancé dans le stand-up ?
Et merde.